warning this episode of weekend ticket
is hosted by a professional anything
said about Johnny Knoxville's action
point or any other jackass related movie
or show should be done by a trained
professional please don't try this at
home or do tell us in the comments
what's your favorite jackass moment this
is your weekend ticket Johnny
Knoxville's action point comes crashing
into theaters this weekend it's a
low-key melodrama with a French New Wave
vibe dialogue heavy and no stunts
whatsoever that's not it oh actually in
typical johnny Knoxville and company
fashion action point is full of
dangerous stunts r-rated humour and just
enough plot to tie it all together based
off a real-life low-rent dangerous New
Jersey theme park or as I like to call
it a New Jersey theme park called action
Park this movie follows action points
fictional owner and his quest to save
the park and his relationship with his
estranged daughter this is our home
don't just let somebody take it follow
the usual johnny Knoxville Chris Pontius
crew this movie is for you if you're
into action comedies are a fan of the
Jackass franchisor johnny Knoxville fat
grandpa or don't mind watching real
people get hit right in the nuts Johnny
Knoxville reported that during the
filming of this movie he got hurt more
than ever
whether we're a lot of troops emergency
room at one point had a blowout fracture
of my left thigh and my left eye comes
out of my head it came out twice came on
another time six days apart went funny
just made me laugh and I mean don't
again it's also worth mentioning that
solo a Star Wars story is still in
theaters opening last week as the
official unofficial kickoff of the
summer movie season you won't want to
miss it
that's your weekend ticket check back
next week for a hotel Artemus a near
future Los Angeles sci-fi with Jodie
Foster and Sterling and Kate brown I'm
sterling kay Brown yes you are see you
next week buddy
[Music]